ya llegaron los helados la siguiente
tabla describe el número de bolas en un
cono de helado representado por x y el
precio del cono representado por g
escribe la ecuación que representa esta
relación bien entonces aquí en la tabla
el número de bolas sería x y el precio
que pagó por el cono de helado sería g
antes que nada voy a convertir todos
estos números mixtos en fracciones
propias o bueno más bien impropias uno
con tres cuartos cuánto es pues es uno
más tres cuartos así que si lo pongo con
denominador cuatro sería lo mismo que
cuatro por uno es 4 377 cuartos tres con
un medio es lo mismo que dos por 13-6
más 177 medios si lo escribo con
denominador 4 tengo que multiplicar el
numerador y el denominador por 2 yo
tengo 14 cuartos
5 con un cuarto sería lo mismo que 4 por
5 es 20 más 121 cuartos y finalmente 77
escrito con denominador 4 sería lo mismo
que 28 cuartos muy bien ahora si estamos
listos para encontrar la ecuación que
representa la relación pues noten que
esta relación es proporcional y que de
hecho x / l
perdón
y que de hecho y / x siempre tiene el
mismo valor y qué valores s
este valor es
este valor es siete cuartos noten que
cuando llegue vale 74 x vale 1 por lo
tanto siete cuartos entre uno y siete
cuartos cuando x vale 14 cuartos perdón
cuando lleva el 14 cuartos cuando
llévale 14 cuartos eso dividido entre 2
es de nuevo a 7 cuartos por lo tanto
esta relación es proporcional otro modo
de escribir esto podría decir si
multiplico todo por x podría multiplicar
por x y acá también por equis y escribir
esto como pues esta x cancela esta x y
resulta que ye
y es igual
es igual a siete cuartos de x es igual a
7 cuartos de xy podemos verificar lo
cuando x vale 0
llévales 0 que sería lo mismo si
sustituyó esos valores aquí cuando x
vale 4 entonces vale 7 por 4 entre 4 que
sería lo mismo que 7 así que esto
funciona vamos a verificarlo
bueno así que solo vamos a escribir aquí
que es igual
7 / 4 x x chequemos muy bien